my talk it's online there's always talks
the peach net Twitter at Rasmus so I'm
old older than I think everyone in this
room maybe with a few or maybe a couple
of exceptions one or two maybe but I'm
turning 50 this year which is in the
source world is quite old at my company
where I work at that see I am one of the
two or three oldest and the company in
this business very in this a young
business it's for young people mostly I
started off hey here we have the other
room coming good welcome I can speed up
I started off in the 80s this was my
first computer Timex Sinclair has like
has 1k of memory the big block on the
back is a 16 K memory expansion module
and I learned to do a lot of low-level
programming because that module was so
big and heavy it would sometimes come
loose so my program would go from having
17 K of memory down to 1 K instantly so
I had to make sure my critical loop were
in the lower 1k at all time so my code
wouldn't crash and they could then
repopulate the upper memory types of
things we don't think about these days
really but maybe with cloud computing
and dynamic memory resizing and things
like that maybe some of this stuff comes
back we'll see vic-20 like many people
dreamt of getting a haze northern so I
could actually go online to interesting
stuff it's been a lot of time sitting
there watching Z modem download stuff
this was the internet for me this was
the web there was no web basically web
started off slowly with gopher and in
the early 1990s worked a bit on that and
it was until 93 when we saw mosaic the
first web browser first graphical web
browser to come out that I really got
into web development full time and
that's when I started at PHP and that's
where the PHP story starts and about mid
to late 1993 or I started building
websites the code of my early stuff
looked like this so these are CGI C
programs you can see HTML inside a c
program any tiny
the UX type of change wanted to make yet
to recompile your C code and redeploy it
and it was really easy to screw up your
C code especially if you're handing off
the visual designs of somebody else back
then handing them a C program and asking
a visual designer not to mess up C that
didn't work so well so I needed a better
solution than this because I hated doing
the front-end stuff I've always hated
doing front-end work I was always a
back-end person so most of the web in 93
switched over to Perl CGI p.m. it's a
perl module that lets you code CGI
programs in Pro to me this wasn't that
much better it just meant that I'm
handing off Perl code to the UX person
and asking them not to screw up Perl
which might actually be a harder ask
than asking me not to screw up see
because Perl can be screwed up in so
many interesting ways so I wanted
something more like this I wanted my
HTML to look like HTML I wanted to be
able to hand off things to the designers
in a way that they couldn't possibly
screw up all right well they could still
mess up HTML by me that's their job they
should know the HTML part and I just
wanted to give them a couple of magical
takes that because add to their library
of HTML that they knew and have them
solve domain-specific problems using
that and I basically give people a cheat
sheet I say okay you know HTML here for
this particular application that we're
working on here are 12 extra fancy tags
that you can use to pull in back-end
data and do interesting stuff with and
that was that was the birth of PHP it
was a templating system for the longest
time and I always resisted this desire
to make it a language and call it a
language to me it was a way of
interfacing HTML and the backend C code
that talked to all the backend systems
the problem was though that people
wanted to do more and more logic in the
templating system
nobody wanted to write C code and I
couldn't convince people to write C code
because the web was growing so fast and
they weren't
see developers in the world my idea of
PHP never came to be my idea of PHP is
not the PHP we have today my idea was
for PHP to be a very well structured C
API for the web where you write all your
business logic in C a fast strongly
typed language and you only do so that
the visual logic that the display logic
in the templating system but the entire
world disagreed with me they wanted to
do all the hard core business logic in
the templating system and yes I had
added some language like features to the
templating system so you could have
snippets of things
snippets of a template that you could
repeat through calling a function and
you could do most sort of language like
things but the intent wasn't to build
business logic in that it was to make it
a very rich templating system and my
ultimate failure came when people
started writing templating systems for
my template existence and at that point
I knew I had lost so having lost that
battle and sort of given in the task
then was to make okay
since this doesn't start off as a
templating or as a programming language
it was a templating system now we have
to switch gears and I have to switch
gears and actually make this rather
crappy templating language a good
programming language and that has taken
some years and there's a lot of legacy
things in there because of that and PHP
gets a lot of criticism because of some
of these legacy features but we've
always strived to not break back with
compatibility because there's just so
much code out there
some people say up to 80% of all
websites have some level of PHP on them
imagine how big the web is and if we go
and break 80 percent of it not cool so
our latest thing was speeding up
existing sites and speeding up the web
we did that with PHP 7 and many sites
will see a hundred percent performance
improvement so
double the speeds some sites will have
even more than that sometimes some sites
will speed up three to four times just
by upgrading from PHP five to PHP seven
and we did that by focusing on memory
usage we started off trying with a JIT
because Facebook's H HBM had shown us
what could be done with a good JIT so
hey let's let's write a JIT and we did
and this JIT created fractals really
really fast
but it didn't speed up your WordPress
site it didn't speed up your Drupal site
it didn't speed up any real-world PHP
sites out there so we abandoned the idea
of a JIT and instead really focused hard
on reducing memory usage and also
improving CPU cache usage worked a bit
with the Intel compiler team and they
helped us profile and narrow down some
of the places we were blowing away l2
caches at the CPU level and a lot of
low-level things like that getting
better data locality for data that we're
moving around means fed stuff from the
database don't copy it from the database
buffer to another buffer to try to keep
it all in one buffer and never moving
things around same when you're calling
functions don't make copy of the
function arguments so a lot of things
were done to make sure that we only ever
put data in memory once and then always
refer back to it and lots of other
interesting tricks so here's a piece of
code that makes a hundred thousand makes
an array with a hundred thousand little
arrays inside so the nest of the rate in
PHP five this takes up a hundred and
nine megabytes of memory PHP seven with
no op cache takes about 42 mega bytes
because of some of these low-level
reductions we made in the hash table and
hash table buckets but we also have an
opcode cache by default now in PHP 7
which is a big chunk of shared memory
where we can toss things in too and
we're actually make use of the shared
memory segment so when you have static
arrays like this we copy it into shared
memory and we store it as an array in
shared memory once so each
client or each process it's either in
the nginx PHP fpm process or might be an
apache child process with mod PHP loaded
in it's actually only stored once in
shared memory and all the individual
processes don't have their own copy
unless you change it if you make a
modification to one of these elements
then that element gets copied down into
a local memory because that change may
not be relevant to the other parallel
processes that are accessing this memory
that gets a little bit complicated
because you have many different
processes all accessing the same memory
so you have to be quite careful and it
took quite a bit of work to get to that
stage but the memory reduction is
dramatic in cases like this like going
from 109 megabytes to 6 megabytes
there's a huge huge memory reduction
some of the other things we did lots and
lots of optimizations across the entire
code base and this this code at the time
was 22 years old this code base now
we're close to 25 years old making an
old code base like this twice as fast
without breaking backward compatibility
is a small miracle I mean this is not an
easy thing to do basically if you look
at low-level instructions we're now
doing the same and work without breaking
anything in 1/3 the number of
instructions that PHP 5 used to do the
thing so basically it's like taking your
code and saying delete 2/3 of it but
make it behave exactly like it did
before
on the code base that's 25 years old
good luck doing that on your own code
base we still don't have a JIT in PHP 7
and we will probably revisit the JIT for
PHP 8 so we still have this opportunity
for a major speed boost all of the speed
improvements in PHP 7 came from the
memory reduction and the optimization
that we did on the core we still have
this opportunity to introduce a JIT so
we may see another big bump all right so
actual numbers here this is WordPress
4.8 running on PHP 5 3 5 4 all the way
up to PHP 7 2 you can see we went from
about 154 requests per second to 540
requests per second going from 5 3 to 7
to this FDO is kind of a special build
of PHP 7 to GCC
the compiler that we use has a cool
feature called feedback directed
optimization FDO and what that means
it's kind of like an external JIT what
you can do is you can build a learning
version of PHP and then you can train it
on your specific data and then you
recompile it a special version you get a
special version of PHP that is tuned
directly for your particular workload so
in this case I am training it for
WordPress so you do make prof. 10 so you
generate this profiling version of PHP
you train it and easy way to do that
it's called PHP CGI - T this is run this
a thousand times and because the front
page of wordpress pulls in basically all
the word press through includes you
don't need to hit any other pages for
your particular stuff you may want to
hit a couple of entry points into your
application then prof clean and make
profuse and that gives you the binary
and that gives you this binary i used
here which is about a to the 3 percent
increase over the non profile the non
optimised version and this is not a PHP
thing you can do that for any Linux
binary you can build an FTO version of
your binary for your particular load all
right what's more important than
straight sort of performance single
process performance is actually memory
use and here we can see how it's gone
down from in WordPress from 5 3 to 7
going from a hundred and forty megabytes
of memory needed for 10 parallel
processes serving up WordPress it's gone
down to 15 that's another massive
massive memory drop and it means if
you're hosting stuff on cloud instances
it means that you can pay for much
smaller instances
to serve up the same amount of traffic
with PHP 7 so the request density of PHP
7 it's more than just the fact that PHP
7 is twice as fast it means that it's
twice as fast and you can put probably
six to eight times more load on that
server so if you have say 80 instances
in the cloud you could probably do the
same work with 10 which is a huge huge
difference at Etsy when I upgraded to
PHP 7 a couple of years ago here is a
graph this is perc 95 response time so
latency with two servers running PHP
five and two servers running PHP seven
so the latency dropped from about 460
milliseconds down to 260 milliseconds so
we cut off 200 milliseconds of latency
on the production Etsy servers by
upgrading with no code changes cpu per
request so CPU usage got cut in half
there abouts and memory went from about
80 megabytes down to 12 megabytes of
memory per httpd process we're using
apache in this case so it was a massive
massive reduction in in hosting needs I
was able to during testing I turned off
2/3 of my production servers at Etsy so
the point where the the ops were
screaming what's going on I mean you're
turning off all our production servers
stop it
this is scary but I was showing them
look we're serving up the same traffic
it's serving up faster with only 1/3 of
our actual servers and it makes a huge
huge difference because they're around 2
billion sites on the web so the web is
hosted on about 10 million physical
machines right now and PHP very
conservatively is on 50% it's likely
much higher than that so right now we're
at five to six percent of the option of
PHP 7 so about 250,000 physical servers
have upgraded
if you start looking at energy usage for
those at 5% adoption lots and lots of
savings lots of less co2 being spewed
out in the atmosphere but I would like
to see go to a hundred percent there's
really no reason not to upgrade to PHP
seven the incompatibility is between PHP
five and PHP seven are quite minor and
it's easy to go back to your PHP seven
and just look at some of your warnings
and look at your notices if you're
running clean PHP five code that doesn't
spew out a ton of warnings and notices
about deprecated things it's gonna be a
very very easy upgrade to PHP seven yes
if your PHP five code looks like PHP
four code that's fused thousands and
thousands of warnings in PHP five you
have a bit of work to do
but it's work that you should be doing
because your code there's ancient them
all right so please please please do
your part upgrade to PHP seven I have a
16 year old son I would like for him to
have a world he can actually live in for
the rest of his life if you don't
upgrade to PHP seven he will get angry
at you
alright so PHP seven - what's new so PHP
72 is the current version of PHP we are
doing some initial DC and sccp
optimizations which probably means
absolutely nothing to you and I'll talk
a little bit more about that in the next
slide some of them more easily to
understand features parameter type
writing widening means that if you are
extending a class you are allowed to
loosen the research the restrictions in
the child class so in this case the
parent is saying this should be an array
and here you're saying well I'm gonna
extend it it still allows an array so
it's still compatible with the parent
but we're also allowing other types at
this point it's for the F n function
here in PHP 71 it would give you a
warning it would complain about that and
there really according to Liskov there
really is no reason why you can't wide
the type so that's one of the changes
again this should not break your code if
you're upgrading from 71 to 72 it just
means a warning is gonna go away nothing
else we're now allowed trailing commas
everywhere we allowed that in a race
before but now sort of with a nod to
great JavaScript comma debate anywhere
you have a list of things separated by
commas and PHP 72 you cannot have a
trailing comma kind of a minor feature
there's an object type int now this
basically allows you to say that
something takes an object doesn't matter
what type of object and something
returns an object whatever type of
object that might be
we've also deprecated uncoded strings
they still work for they will spew a
warning it was kind of a weird legacy
feature from ages and ages ago you could
put in a string and if it didn't match a
constant it would just be treated as a
string even though it didn't have quotes
around it and it still works because
some code relies on that but it's gonna
go away in the next major version of PHP
so we're spewing out warnings for it now
and you can pass extra headers to the
male function as an array again quite a
minor feature we've also added argon to
I which is a hashing mechanism and
probably the biggest feature of 72 is
we've moved away from m crypt completely
now and everything is now based on Lib
sodium which is an encryption library M
crypt is in heavy you still but it
hasn't been updated in about eight years
its unmaintained an unmaintained crypto
security library is a really really bad
situation to be in so we're now using a
maintained lip sodium library there's a
really good online book about lip sodium
here if you want to learn more about it
but all your encryption needs can
basically be solved through sodium calls
now things that may break your code like
I said we've moved completely away from
M crypt this already warned in PHP 71
saying this stuff is deprecated it's
gonna go away and it's now completely
been removed in 72 that's probably your
most the most of your work upgrading to
PHP 72 is probably
be encrypt related and a couple of other
really old features have been removed
that might break your stuff or at least
be warnings now all right so I promised
I'd talk a little bit about DCE and sccp
so DC e stands for dead code elimination
another term we use is escape analysis
and sparse conditional constant
propagation what this all means is that
we will go and look at the code and see
if there is anything that doesn't need
to be there before we cash the op codes
in the OP cash so if you write code like
this equals 1 return 0 what's the point
of this a equals 1 here like absolutely
nothing right the way PHP handles global
variables you have to declare Global's
so this can have absolutely no side
effect and that's where escape analysis
comes in we analyze this and see is
there any way for this dollar a variable
to escape this context and there isn't
so in PHP 7 1 this would actually do
exactly what you asked it to and it
would assign int int 1 to dollar a and
return 0 and that's the opcodes that
would get cashed in PHP 7 2 we
completely remove that assignment so
that a equals 1 is as if it wasn't even
there because what gets cashed in the OP
code cache is just return 0 so every
subsequent request after the first one
won't even see that and it has no impact
on the code whatsoever we can try more
complicated things so in this case we're
passing in four strings we're catenate
and together putting that result in X
then we overwrite that X variable and we
return X and here PHP 72 is smart it
still receives the variables but that's
actually a no op it doesn't do anything
it so that entire function here is just
replaced with return 0 you can also see
the X variable went away because
actually equal 0 return X there's no
reason to make that assignment either
because that whole function reduces down
to just as if you had written returns or
in your function which obviously runs
much faster than having to execute all
these op codes in PHP 7 1 you can try to
trick it so in this case I mean this is
legal PHP B equals a plus equals 3 and
PHP 72 is smart enough to see that
there's absolutely no reason for B to be
in here so B is eliminated so we just
add 3 to a and return that some things
that aren't you can trick it a little
further and 72 doesn't quite have the
smarts yet in PHP 73 we're making this
even smarter so in this case you just do
the assignment here and then return a
PHP 71 couldn't quite figure this case
out in 7 3 it can also figure out object
stuff so in this case it does escape
analysis one level up to figure out is
there any point in this instantiation of
object a and it looks at the object and
sees well we're just assigning a
property but nothing is happening with
that property there's no point in any of
this just get rid of it so this entire
function gets reduced to just it as if
you had written return dollar x if you
added the structure to it then suddenly
escape analysis say wait a second that
the structure might do something and in
this case we can't eliminate
instantiating the a object because in
case the destructor does something and
we're currently only going one level up
to check to see if they're constructors
and destructors if there is a function
that will get called on the object
getting that's constructed or destructed
then we know hey there's a chance this
will escape and we can't reduce it down
to something simpler stuff like this
here PHP 73 is slightly more efficient
than PHP 72 here you basically go
through we figure everything out and
this function with this function ends up
just being returned for right if you do
the math on this thing you don't need to
create
and because this stuff will always
return for nothing else it also
understands conditionals and this one's
kind of cool if you walk through it you
will see that nothing ever gets done
other than return zero here no matter
what X is because it's only looking at a
zero this 1 & 2 doesn't matter so the if
X doesn't matter this function will
always return zero and the escape
analysis and sccp is smart enough to
reduce all this down just to return zero
which is quite magical actually and then
you can go a little bit crazy right here
you have an example while all this code
gets reduced to echo 1 return 4 and
that's all PHP will execute and the end
result of all this is that if you write
really really crappy code PHP 7/2 and
PHP 7 3 even more so it's going to run
it really really fast
if you run decent code you're not gonna
see as much of a speed a speed-up from
PHP 73 and 72 but it's been sort of PHP
sting forever
PHP runs crappy code really really well
it runs it fast and it works and that's
why PHP has become so popular because
you try something and it just works and
heck is even fast very few other
languages can say that it's not always
great but it really helps people get
started with it and it doesn't prevent
people from writing better code in the
future it's just that they don't have
this huge pressure to write better code
so you end up with some bad code and
that's where static analysis comes in
which was my next topic so I wrote this
static analysis tool called fan you can
find it at github.com slash fan very
easy to install be a composer or you can
install it directly just by cloning from
github you can initialize the - dashing
it creates a dot fan config dot PHP and
you can run the vendor bin fan on your
project
and it checks all kinds of things if you
have phpdoc type annotations in there
it'll check they're correct check that
all methods are defined everything you
anything you call in any constants
properties that you try to access in
your code it's all defined and at the
all right access level for you to call
it checks type safety everywhere version
compatibility checks for no ops
unreachable code unused statements all
kinds of things you can also write
plugins that extend the stagnant
analyzer to check for whatever you want
and there's a bunch of included plugins
I'm gonna demo a few of them so here I
have a bit of PHP code and I'm actually
showing the vim integration because I'm
a big guy bi guy forever if I were to
change this constructor to say this
returns an integer and I save the file
it's complaining wait a second
constructors can't declare a return type
because it makes no sense
nothing's gonna catch this return value
so fan can catch stuff like that loops
oh my undo other things say you miss the
bracket on the count I mean this is
syntactically ballot in not what you
meant to do right if I try to say that
it gives you all kinds of errors saying
wait a second non bool is evaluated in
if which is one of the user plugins I
have enabled right now but you also have
this array to in comparison where you're
comparing an array to an integer which
is valid but it's probably not what you
meant to do so here a fan can come in
and really help out with silly things it
also lets you have array shapes in the
sense that you can say this property R
is an array with the key is always an
integer and the value is always a string
and if at some point you decide to
assign an integer into this array you'll
see wait a second you're assigning an
integer but properties see ARR is
defined to be an array of int string
type
right so here it catches the fact that
you're putting in a value that you said
shouldn't be possible because you said
it should only be int with string values
it also does even more if you mess up a
red X it actually can go and look at
your records and say hey this is not a
valid rekhs and this is before running
your code right this is just a static
analyzer going through and also even
printf strings and stuff so here we're
passing a string to a printf and you can
figure out let's say wait a second
you're passing in a string but you're
using percent d in your printf string
which actually means integer so that's
probably not gonna do what you want it
to do and also one of the user plugins
you can do things like tell it well I'm
not going to allow something like this
oops personally I love dollar dollar
variables but I know many people don't
and here you can add the plug-in there's
a dollar dollar plugin for fan we can
make that so other day company why Paul
don't do dollar dollar stuff in our code
base at this company and let's see we
run fan on what people can run it
individually on their own machines but
we also run it as part of the test suite
so if you're going to push something to
production it has to pass all our fan
checks including our plug-in things and
it catches a ton of silly mistakes
before it hits production because unless
you have 100% code coverage and your
unit tests which nobody does and that's
a waste of time trying to get to 1%
you're going to need a static analyzer
like this to help catch things all right
I am completely out of time
thank you very much and there are
references here to everything I talked
about
[Applause]
[Music]